اوقاتنا اينما كنتم بانوراما من العربيه
يقدمها لكم صهيب شراير هذه عناوينها
تصويت البرلمان الاردني على طرد السفير
الاسرائيلي ماذا يعني وما هي التداعيات
هل نجحت ترامب في استثمار لانباء اعتقاله
في استعاده زخم حملته الانتخابيه ام ان
هناك مفاجاه جديده تنتظره مخباه في حقيبه
المدعي العام الامريكي
بعد الاجراءات الغربيه المتتاليه للتضييق
على تطبيق تيك توك وربما حظره لماذا يتنكر
الغرب لاحد منتجات عصر العولمه خوفا من
التمدد في النفوذ الصيني ام لاسباب امنيه
وثقافيه
بالاغلبيه اذا اوصى البرلمان الاردني بطرد
السفير الاسرائيلي
من البلاد بعد ازمه الخريطه والتصريحات
العنصريه التي ادلى بها وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي
وطلب ايمن الصفدي وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه
طالب باجراءات فاعله ومؤثره تجاه استخدام
وزير ماليه اسرائيل خريطه مزعومه تضم حدود
المملكه والاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وفق
قوله التوصيه بطرد سوركس من عمان تاتي عقب
استدعاء وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه الاثنين
الماضي السفير الاسرائيلي احتجاجا على
استخدام وزير الماليه اليميني خريطه
لاسرائيل تضم الاردن والاراضي الفلسطينيه
فضلا عن تصريحات انكر فيها وجود
الفلسطينيين كافراد وكشعب او ثقافه
فلسطينيه ووجهت هذه التصريحات تصريحات
التي القاها خلال امسيه نظمتها الاحد
الماضي جماعه اسرائيليه متطرفه في باريس
لاقت انتقادات عربيه ودوليه حاده وايضا من
قبل واشنطن
[موسيقى]
البرلمان الاردني يوصي بطرد السفير
الاسرائيلي من البلاد
تصويت مجلس النواب غير ملزم وحسب الدستور
الاردني فان اي قرار يجب ان يحظى بموافقه
الحكومه الاردنيه ثم الملك
رغم ذلك جاءت التوصيه بالطرد
الشرق الاوسط ما قام به وزير الاحتلال ينم
عن غطرسه اسرائيليه لا تحترم المعاهدات
والمواثيق الدوليه
ونناقش الموضوع من عمان مع الدكتور حسن
المومني استاذ العلاقات الدوليه ومن القدس
مع شلوموغانور المحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما
ضيفي الكريمين دكتور حسن ابدا معك
مجلس النواب الاردني اذا يصوت لصالح طرد
السفير الاسرائيلي من عمان ولكن حسب
الدستور الاردني فهذا القرار غير ملزم هو
يجب ان يحظى بموافقه الحكومه الاردنيه
بشكل مباشر هل سيتم طرد السفير الاسرائيلي
من الاردن
بتقدير الشخصي مساء الخير
والى المشاهدين بتقدير الشخصي الان يمكن
احتماليه طرد السفير يعني اكبر من ذي قبل
بهذا المعنى بهذا الاتجاه اخذينا بعين
الاعتبار هذه الهستيريا التصعيديه الصادره
من حكومه نتنياهو الذي هو بالاساس فقد
السيطره عليها فما قام به البرلمان
الاردني هو جزء من مجموعه اجراءات اتخذتها
وقد تتخذها الدوله الاردنيه في هذا السياق
وفي هذا الاتجاه والبرلمان هناك طبعا
نتحدث عن ما يسمى في الدبلوماسيه
البرلمانيه الشعبيه بهذا الامر صحيح ان
البرلمان اوصى ولا يملك السلطه على
الحكومه بان تنفذها لكن لا تنسى ان في
نهايه المطاف البرلمان له اليد العليا
بحيث انه يستطيع ان يطرح الثقه بالحكومه
بهذا الجانب فلذلك هنالك حقيقه يعني
بتقدير الشخص تنسيق ما بين السلطات بهذا
الامر لانه الامر الان بت في المصالح
الاستراتيجيه العليا للدوله الاردنيه
وبالتالي اداره ازمه اخذه من اتساع مع
اسرائيل في هذا السياق وبالتالي كل
الاحتمالات مطروحه على الطاوله خاصه في
السياق السياسي الدبلوماسي نعم سيد ضيفي
من عمان يصف هذا
الاستفزاز من قبل
بانه هستيريا من حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
هنا اريد ان اسال سؤال لماذا يتصرف هكذا
ليست هذه المره الاولى في تصريحات سابقه
اثارت يعني غضب العالم عندما دعا الى محو
بلده حواره في نابلس الان هو يضع خريطه
تضم الاردن والاراضي الفلسطينيه ويمكن
وجود شعب فلسطيني اصلا لماذا يتصرف بهذه
الطريقه هل هو يسعى فقط للاستفزاز ام هذه
هي عقليه او ايديولوجيه حزب الصهيونيه
الدينيه الذي يتراسه
يجب التوضيح بانه اسرائيل تبررت
رسميا من اقوال
وبهذا الصدد صدرت عده بيانات رسميه من
دماغ رئيس الوزراء من وزير الخارجيه من
المستشار الامن القومي وايضا اجريت
الاتصالات بهذا الصدد باعتبار المسؤولين
الاردنيين لتوضيح الموقف الاسرائيلي
الرسمي الذي لا يؤيد ولا يتضامن ولا يقف
وراء تصريحات
بتاتا ولا حتى عن قريب ولذلك يجب اعتبار
اقوال
بناء تمثله شخصيا ولا تمثل دوله اسرائيل
جاء بالنسبه للقرار الذي اتخذ به مجلس
النواب اعتقد بانه اسف مثل هذا القرار
وقال لها تحول
المجلس النواب الاردني الى منبر عدواني
اسرائيل لا يعرف الاعضاء الحقيقه الاوضاع
الاستراتيجيه القصه القائمه لاسرائيل
النواب معرضون لدعايه محرضه ضد اسرائيل ضد
معاهده السلام ولهذا يوسف عليها بالنسبه
ساعود اليك لو سمحت ولكن هذه يجب ان اسال
عنها ضيفي من عمان دكتور حسن ما رايك في
مقاله سيد شلوموجانور هل التبرا حكومه
نتنياهو من تصريحات سموترش وكذلك طبعا
تصرفات وكذلك بنكفير يعبران عن صوت متشدد
اقصى اليمين في هذه الحكومه وبات يحرج
حكومه نتنياهو هل التبرا من هذه التصريحات
يكفي الاردن
للتراجع عن طرد السفير الاسرائيلي يا ترى
اخي العزيز يعني هذا تبسيط لما حصل هنالك
حاله انفصام تعصف الحكومه الاسرائيليه بين
الاقوال والافعال ومساله لعبه الملامه
والتبرع هذا تكتيك حقيقه يعبر ايضا عن عجز
وعن عدم قدره نتنياهو على ضبط الامور او
قد تختلف اولوياته في السياق الشخصي في
مساله تحصين نفسه من خلال تغيير
النظام القضائي وغيره بهذا الجانب قبل ذلك
كان بن جبير الان متحدث عن يعني المساله
مش مساله انه والله حاله فرديه وبالتالي
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه استمر فيها على
العكس في هنالك حاله انفصام نرى اقوال في
العقبه نرى اقوال في في شرم الشيخ وبنفس
الوقت نرى افعال مختلف كليا على ارض
الواقع تغير الحقائق وعلى العكس من ذلك
يعني هؤلاء المسؤولين هم جزء من الحكومه
ليس افراد وبالتالي هم يعني
كما يصفها الدكتور حسن المومني في عمان
طيب اذا كان بن قدير هذه الاصوات اليمينيه
تحرج نتنياهو وتسبب ازمات لاسرائيل مع
حلفائها وغيرها من دول المنطقه
فلماذا لا يقوم نتنياهو بالاستغناء او
اقاله هؤلاء الوزراء ام انه يخشى دفع ثمن
سقوط الحكومه
نعم هذا بالتاكيد ممكن نقول بكل صراحه كل
امانه بانه اسير لهذا الائتلاف الحكومي
اليميني المتطرف ليس بوسعه التحكم
واداره ما يريد واذا نحن نتناول العلاقات
الاسرائيليه الاردنيه يجب الاشاره هنا بان
بعيده تشكيل هذه الحكومه بايام كفضل
نتنياهو ان يقوم بزياره رسميه لعمان
الى العائله الاردني وذلك ليس فقط لتكريم
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه بل
لاثاره المواضيع الاقتصاديه الاستراتيجيه
السياسيه
من عمان يعني هذا يعتبر حتى يعني تكتيكا
او ينظر اليه لانه في النهايه هناك صوت في
الحكومه ذهب بعيدا الان في العداء او
التصريحات العدائيه تجاهه
دوله تقيم
معاهده سلام مع مع اسرائيل هو وضع خريطه
تضم اسرائيل وفلسطين والمملكه الاردنيه
واحده وانكر وجود الشعب الفلسطيني هل يعني
هذا واضح ان التبرا او انه اي زياره يعني
لن تقنع الجانب الاردني بان هذا لا يمثل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
سيدي هذه هي الخارطه السياسيه الاسرائيليه
التي فرضت نفسها على نتنياهو لدى تشكيله
لائتلاف الحكومي الحالي وعليه ايجاد مخرج
من هذا الموضوع المفتاح هو بايدي ربما هذا
الوزير ذلك ممكن ان
يصرحان باشياء لا يقبلها المجتمع
الاسرائيلي باسره وعلى سبيل المثال
العلاقات مع الاردن على سبيل المثال
الاعتراف بالشعب الفلسطيني على سبيل
المثال وجود معاهده سلام ووجود مملكه
اردنيه هاشميه بالكامل سيادتها على التراب
الهاشمي
بالشرقيه الاردن قلنا هذا هو من من
المسلمات لدى المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولكن
هي
ايديولوجيهه ولا تمثل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
لا تمثل الحكومه الايطاليه وايضا لا تمثل
العلاقات العمليه على الارض بين البلد
ولكن حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الذي يتزعمه
هو جزء من هذه الحكومه جزء من التحالف مع
الرئيس
دكتور حسن المومني دعني اسالك كما قال
السيد هذه هي المعادله في المشهد السياسي
في اسرائيل هناك تحالف في اصوات متشدده
وهذه هي ايديولوجيتها يعني هم لا يسعون
للاستفزاز بل هم مقتنعون بانه لا يوجد شعب
فلسطيني وبان هذه هي حدود اسرائيل من وجهه
نظرهم بالنسبه للاردن ما هي الخيارات الان
هناك خطوه في البرلمان الاردني
بتوصيه الحكومه بطرد السفير الاسرائيلي
الى اين يمكن ان يصل الغضب الاردني
يعني هو بدايه خليني اوضح مشكله اسرائيل
مش بس مع الاردن الان مشكله اسرائيل اصبحت
مع العالم اليوم الامريكان استدعوا
السفينه الاسرائيلي بهذا الجانب للاتحاد
الاوروبي موقفه من هذا الامر يعني المشكله
ليست في موضوع الاردن هلا بالنسبه للاردن
خياراته من بلا في سياسيه دبلوماسيه
وبالمناسبه يعني يعني يجب اخذ بعين
الاعتبار ما يسمى في رده الفعل الشعبيه
الاردنيه بهذا الاتجاه حتى لو افترضنا ان
الحكومه والدوله الاردنيه تتصرف بعقلانيه
وبمنطق وفي سلاح وتعاير بهذا المصالح نعم
لكن ايضا هنالك ضغط شعبي وانت تعلم ان
القضيه الفلسطينيه هي مساله داخليه ومساله
سياسه خارجيه بهذا المعنى الان مساله هذا
انه الله اسرائيل او الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تبرر ان هنالك مجموعه لاخي العزيز هذه
المجموعه تمثل تيار اسرائيل متطرف له جذور
العقائديه تمتد الى ما يسمى في عقليه
الجدار الحديده بهذا المعنى من ايام
جابتنسكي هذا الاتجاه عندما انت تنفي شعب
كامل عندما تتحدث عن اسرائيل الكبرى عندها
عندما وفي نهايه المطاف هل على المنطقه او
على الاردن يعني يتحمل هذه حاله الانفصال
الانفصال هذه مشكله اسرائيل مشكله نتنياهو
وبالتالي حسابات الربح والخساره بهذا
الجانب الربح والخساره مهمه جدا هنا
كما قال ضيفي من عمان يعني تصريحات
موتريتش وخرجته هذه لا تشكل ازمه لاسرائيل
مع الاردن فقط بل مع الحليف الرئيسي مع
الولايات المتحده مع الامارات كذلك التي
اقامت علاقات مع مع اسرائيل مع اثاره غضب
الدول العربيه الاخرى وعديد الدول
فبالتالي هنا اسال الى اي حد يعني هذا هذه
الفاتوره تستطيع الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان
تتحملها الان
كما قلت نتنياهو سيره لاتلاف الحكوميه
الحالي واعتقد انه يحاول بكل قوه ايجاد
مخرجا من هذه الازمه الائتلافيه التي هو
يتواجد فيها والتي تتفاقم يوما بعد يوم
ليس فقط في العلاقات الاسرائيليه الخارجيه
بل ايضا داخليا
مصر تشهد
لكن ما شكل هذا المخرج هل هناك مخرج
نتنياهو اذا اقال سموتريتش وبنجفير تسقط
حكومته فورا وهو ايضا يعاني من اضطرابات
داخليه كذلك وغضب شعبي بسبب اصلاح النظام
القضائي في اسرائيل فما عساه يكون المخرج
بالنسبه
لنتنياهو حتى يستعيد بعض العلاقات مع
حلفائه
اولا محاوله
صرف النظر عن تصرفات هؤلاء
والتقليل من اهميتهم هذا وهذا ما يحاول
باصدار البيانات الرسميه التي هو يقف
وراها هذا من جهه من جهه ثانيه هناك ايضا
محاولات لارضاء جهات داخل المعارضه
الاسرائيليه لكي تنضم الى الائتلاف
الحكومي وتسد محل هولئك الاحزاب المتطرفه
ولكن هذا ليس في متناول اليد القريب ربما
في المستقبل قد يبدل ذلك وهناك ايضا
المخرج ربما الاخيره الاخير بالنسبه
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وايضا بالنسبه وهو ان
يتنحى عن عن الحكم وهذا ايضا وارد في
الحسبان ولكن اعتقد بان تطورات الامور
عدنا الى موضوع العلاقات الايطاليه
الاردنيه باسرائيل الجهات الامنيه تنظر
بقلق الى تردي هذه العلاقات خاصه في ضوء
تفاهمات شرم الشيخ والعقبه واعتقد بان كيف
كما هي مصلحه للاردن في علاقاتها
نعم الدكتور المؤمني ما هو المخرج الذي
يناسب الاردن
احنا بالتقدير الشخصي لطالما مكان الاردن
يدعو الى تهدئه وبالتالي هذا الاشتباك
الاردني مع الاطراف المعنيه الاطراف
العربيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
اسرائيل الفلسطينيين بهذا الجانب وحاول
الاردن جاهدا ان يخلق عمليه سياسيه سواء
كانت في العقبه في شرم الشيخ مع الشركاء
الرئيسيين هذه العمليه السياسيه الهدف من
وراء حقيقه خلق ظروف تؤدي الى التهدئه
وبالتالي ايضا امكانيه ان تسالف العمليه
السلميه بين الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليين لكن
بتقدير الشخصي انا الان هنا على اسرائيل
ان تفرق ما بين المصالح الشخصيه المتمثله
في مصالح
وما بين المصالح الحليه العليا للدوله
الاسرائيليه هو هو يعني ما تقوم به
الحكومه الحاليه الاسرائيليه تضر بالمصالح
الاسرائيليه بهذا الامر هل عزنت اسرائيل
من مصلحه اسرائيل هل توتر السلام الذي دعت
اليه اسرائيل عبر عقود من مصلحه اسرائيل
وبالمناسبه يعني انا باكد لك تراهن
اسرائيل على مساله المصالح الاستراتيجيه
وهو يعني في زي المثل المصري يعني
اسمع اقوالك تعجبني اشوف افعالك
نعم فهذه المراهنه يعني الى هذا الامر
اضيف الى ذلك ما الذي يضمن انه لن يكون
هنالك اجراءات استفزازيه قادمه بهذا
الجانب بغض النظر عن عقلانيه الحكومه في
الاردن او الدوله الاردنيه لكن عزيز لابد
من ان يكون هنالك رفع تكلفه على اسرائيل
اعتذر منك انتهى وقتي في هذا الجزء
الدكتور حسن المومني استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه من عمان واشكرك
المحلل السياسي كنت معنا من القدس